[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález 12 de
octubre una fecha controvertida es la
fecha en la que es conmemorado el día de
la hispanidad el día de la raza el día
de los pueblos indígenas el día de la
resistencia indígena o simplemente el
día del descubrimiento entre otros
su nombre varía dependiendo desde donde
sea mirada esta fecha han pasado más de
500 años desde que terminó el viaje de
cristóbal colón desde españa hasta
américa y cinco siglos después el
significado de su viaje y también la
llegada de los españoles no logra
conseguir un consenso y todavía sigue
generando debates discrepancias y
discusiones en torno a diferentes temas
que comprende la conquista del
continente americano
el controvertido 12 de octubre el día
como ustedes lo quieran llamar porque
depende de la perspectiva que lo quieran
ver es nuestro tema de debate en france
24 para profundizar en este tema
saludamos a la doctora alejandra voz a
ella es profesora catedrática de la
escuela de historia de la universidad de
costa rica también es investigadora del
programa de investigación de las
sociedades centroamericanas en el mundo
colonial y la modernidad ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de san josé la
capital costarricense también está con
nosotros fernando huanacuni él es
docente universitario e investigador de
la cosmovisión ancestral y la historia
de los pueblos indígenas originarios ex
canciller de bolivia en el año 2017 se
encuentra en la ciudad de quito la
capital ecuatoriana y aquí conmigo en el
estudio de france 24 se encuentra ati
quigua ella es lideresa indígena awá acá
también es comisionada indígena de paz y
también es concejala de la ciudad de
bogotá ustedes también pueden participar
en este debate pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos en france 24 guión bajo esa
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal le
recuerdo que la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios también el departamento de
internet de france 24 ha publicado una
encuesta en la que aborda uno de los
temas que concierne a este tema de la
conquista y del 12 de octubre y hacen
una pregunta en particular en países
como bolivia y méxico el 12 de octubre
ha cambiado de nombre para significar o
resignificar esta fecha y reivindicar a
los pueblos indígenas qué opinan ustedes
de estos cambios que se proponen desde
américa latina' esperamos todos sus
comentarios participen también nos
interesa saber cuáles son sus
comentarios voy a comenzar en el estudio
de france 24 preguntándole a ati que se
encuentra aquí conmigo en el estudio si
deberíamos conmemorar o no el 12 de
octubre una fecha que genera tanta
controversia cinco siglos después de la
llegada de los españoles
interesante mirar la tendencia en
twitter el día de hoy nada que celebrar
que esa es la consigna aquí en colombia
y yo creo que en toda esta américa para
nosotros abya yala
realmente hace 500 años inicia el saqueo
la imposición de un modelo económico que
vino por el oro pero que hoy viene por
el petróleo viene por el agua es ese
modelo económico extractivista que ha
sido la servidumbre de américa y que
también fue la esclavitud de áfrica así
que
aquí se se repudian todas las formas de
violencia la violencia directa el
genocidio la falocracia la violencia
sexual contra las mujeres el despojo del
territorio pero también la violencia
estructural el racismo la exclusión la
discriminación la violencia cultural la
imposición de una cultura dominante de
un sistema de valores sobre el resto de
las culturas así que hoy es un día más
bien para pasar de la resistencia no
conmemorar la resistencia a los pueblos
pero también para pensar en los desafíos
que tenemos como como humanidad y pensar
en el buen vivir
importante punto de vista a ti aquí en
el estudio de france 24 le pregunto
ahora la doctora alejandra en la ciudad
de san josé en costa rica si se debe
conmemorar esta fecha que genera tanta
controversia ya tenemos un punto de
vista por parte de ati aquí en el
estudio que piensa usted
quizás
podríamos empezar por recordar cuál es
el origen de la conmemoración del 12 de
octubre
que surge en el cuarto centenario de lo
que en ese momento se celebró como el
cuarto centenario de la conquista en
1892 como una celebración podríamos
decirle de la hispanidad o de la
latinidad en contraste con lo que se
veía en esa época como el imperialismo
estadounidense y a partir de ahí ha sido
se planteó como una celebración de esos
valores
hispanoamericanos por decirle así
vinculado sobre todo con la herencia
española la herencia castellana
entonces ya de entrada tiene un origen
muy complicado muy cuestionado esta
celebración
y
[Música]
pienso que no sería que se tendría
sentido pensar si lo que realmente como
sociedades queremos celebrar es la
diversidad la sobrevivencia y la
fuerza de nuestras poblaciones indígenas
de repente tendría sentido pensar en
otra fecha que represente mejor eso una
fecha que ojalá tenga significado
continental pero otra fecha que pueda
representar eso y no que nos mantenga en
este en este debate
del 12 de octubre justamente porque en
su origen
ya es una idea muy problemática sí y
todos los años estamos con este mismo
tema de debate sobre la mesa cada vez
que se aproxima esta fecha en américa
latina' fernando huanacuni en la ciudad
de quito le hago la misma pregunta si
deberemos deberíamos conmemorar el 12 de
octubre vale la pena conmemorar esta
fecha
ya lo hemos llamado de las diferentes
formas que se le llama a esta fecha
dependiendo del punto de vista que se le
mide cuál es su perspectiva al respecto
bueno primero
nosotros debemos mirar la historia con
la honestidad y con la verdad para los
pueblos indígenas originarios de este en
1492 durante la colonia y la república
han sido la noche más oscura de nuestra
historia por las consecuencias del
producto de la invasión y el saqueo en
1492 empezó un proceso de superposición
cultural no fue un proceso de
interculturalidad por lo tanto cuando
nosotros decimos genocidio pues no lo
estamos hablando simplemente por decirlo
porque ha habido consecuencia entre las
naciones de nuestros pueblos se cuenta
que los antropólogos según los
antropólogos de eeuu que en el año 1492
había 100 millones de habitantes pero
para mil 537 cuando se hace un censo
solamente habían 10 millones de
habitantes todo ese genocidio afectó a
los pueblos indígenas originarios porque
cuando llegaron los europeos cuando
entregaron los españoles vinieron con
una premisa una premisa de una adicción
en la que no se veía como iguales a los
pueblos indígena originarios más aún y
dijeron que se parecían más a las
bestias humanas que a las bestias en el
sentido de que no había una
intencionalidad de ver como igual más
aún nuestras prácticas culturales de la
identidad prácticas culturales que
nosotros hemos heredado pues toda la
visión hegemónica
trató de borrar lo tanto de desconocer
de borrar nuestra memoria la de borrar
nuestra identidad por lo tanto pues se
no hay nada que celebrar más de lo
contrario invitamos a una reflexión
histórica para poder hacer una revisión
importante porque para los pueblos
indígena vitico es importante tener una
visión histórica desde la honestidad y
la verdad pues vamos a ver otro punto de
vista en el programa directo américa mi
compañero raúl blanco conversó con jose
manuel azcona él es catedrático de
historia contemporánea de la universidad
rey juan carlos en la ciudad de madrid
en españa
el señor azcona nos dio
perspectiva de lo que significó la
conquista para los españoles el punto de
vista desde el otro lado del atlántico
escuchemos porque es de seguir hablando
así en españa se llama el día de la
hispanidad nueva novela raza porque es
la fecha que conmemoramos en la llegada
la presencia de de mi país y toda la
obra magnífica civilizatoria aquí son
américa por supuesto no pedir perdón a
nadie qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
bien usted nosotros los españoles
hemos sido invadidos por los pueblos
neolíticos del este de europa por los
visigodos por los fenicios por los
griegos por los musulmanes y por los
franceses en 1808
no debe hacer la relación de todos los
pueblos europeos que han sido invadidos
por otros y aquí es que es tan absurdo o
sea tan absurdo en esta parte del mundo
intentar pedir perdón o que alguien nos
perdone que nosotros nos enfrentaríamos
con franceses italianos
fenicios secretas para mis absurdos a es
una polémica que no nada tiene que ver
con la historia
una polémica que nada tiene que ver con
la historia un debate que tiene que ver
con estos hechos y ya lo dice este
invitado no hay nada que pedir perdón
españa debe pedir perdón a ti desde su
punto de vista
estamos en el marco de una pandemia y de
una crisis civilizatoria
el 22% de este mundo es territorio
indígena se hablan 7 mil lenguas yo creo
que hoy la humanidad en el marco de esta
crisis civilizatoria debe repensar su
proyecto civilizatorio fíjense dónde
está la biodiversidad el hogar de todos
los seres y especies de esta tierra en
nuestros territorios donde está el
futuro de este hogar llamado biosfera en
nuestros territorios
sobre la base de nuestro sistema de
conocimiento sobre la preservación de
nuestras culturas y ecosistemas que
depende la vida de todas las especies
incluyendo la especie humana entonces lo
primero es que yo creo que tenemos que
preguntar qué entiende españa por
proyecto civilizatorio desde las mujeres
indígenas
vengo de una cumbre amazónica queremos
recordarle a su humanidad que nuestro
proyecto civilizatorio ha sido de hacer
de este este mundo un jardín un jardín
biológico entonces primera cosa yo creo
que en lo que
las grandes potencias llaman
civilización es el camino de la
autodestrucción
entonces esto tiene que ver con
cuestionar esos discursos esos modelos
de desarrollo que hoy nos conducen
estamos en medio de un calentamiento
global y lo que nos indica la realidad
es que los únicos que hemos cuidado este
hogar llamado tierra somos los pueblos
indígenas entonces yo creo que aquí hay
un problema en nombre de la civilización
no podemos justificar esas violencias
entonces yo creo que necesitamos una
versión de la historia más plural y eso
significa también el reconocimiento a la
verdad indígena el derecho a la
reparación el derecho a la no repetición
de esas violencias porque hoy lo que
vemos es que está
violencia histórica acumulada cada vez
es más sofisticada más sutil pero más
profunda y es desconocer deshumanizar
los las diversidades culturales de la
humanidad para poder imponerles
precisamente un proyecto civilizatorio
que para nosotros no es proyecto
civilizatorio es autodestrucción pero
ese proceso civilizatorio se puede
cuestionar en este momento en pleno 2021
a ti cuando fue un proceso que ocurrió
hace 500 años hace cinco siglos fue que
llegaron los españoles y se están
haciendo reclamos de cosas de hace cinco
siglos hoy en día el panorama es
distinto la civilización y la sociedad
es diferente y ustedes pueden reclamar y
se pueden reclamar desde ambas partes de
formas diferentes no se está haciendo de
pronto un reclamo sobre algo que ya
sucedió hace mucho tiempo y que hay que
ver el ahora lo que usted dice al
calentamiento global lo que está
sucediendo en este momento y enfocarse
en el presente
cinco siglos
y hoy este tiempo nos da la razón
tenemos que unir todos nuestros saberes
tenemos que unir todas nuestras culturas
hoy yo creo que necesitamos una justicia
epistémica en primer lugar es decir son
los sistemas de conocimiento de los
pueblos indígenas los que hoy están
preservando la vida y yo creo que esa es
una verdad irrefutable entonces lo que
le reclamamos a todos quienes nos han
invitado a este proyecto civilizatorio
paren ya la destrucción
hagamos las paces con la tierra y me
parece que partir de allí implica
realmente reflexionar como especie
humana entonces
cinco siglos y quieren seguir
perpetuando las relaciones sociales de
dominio quieren y seguir imponiendo una
cultura mayoritaria que se agotó en sus
modos de producción en su modo de
consumo hoy realmente necesitamos volver
al origen volver a la madre tierra
juntos pero yo creo que si no hay
realmente una sanación de la historia y
eso significa sanar el ser sanar los
saberes es decir si no hay un diálogo
intercultural y sanar el poder y esto
tiene que ver con las relaciones
globales de poder
sanar los territorios y para ello yo
creo que es necesario entender
precisamente que lo que llaman
desarrollo y lo que llaman progreso es
para nosotros la geopolítica de la sed y
el hambre y la destrucción de la tierra
entonces sobre esto yo creo que es una
buena oportunidad para invitar a
descolonizar el saber el poder los
territorios y el ser
con la palabra sanar dejémosla y sobre
la mesa vamos a conversar
sobre esta palabra un poco más adelante
quiero preguntarle a alejandra en la
ciudad de san josé sobre
este proceso civilizatorio si todavía
estos reclamos básicamente lo que le
está preguntando a ti si 500 años
después es válido hacer este tipo de
reclamos cuando la civilización está en
otros escenarios en otros momentos y hay
otra forma de interacción entre las
diferentes culturas es válido usted cómo
lo ve
a ver pienso que pues la justamente el
comentario del señor es una muestra lo
actual que en este proceso sobre todo la
idea que persiste de que
la invasión del continente y trajo
civilización en algún sentido del
continente lo que es pienso yo lo que lo
que parece ser a lo que él se refería
con esta idea de la obra civilizatoria
entonces el que este tipo de ideas
persistan hoy en día
quiere decir que no es algo que terminó
simplemente porque el evento que estemos
pensando sucede hace 500 años no es
decir se siguen pensando muchas
sociedades alrededor del mundo se siguen
siguen pensando el mundo de hoy en día
en esos términos en términos de
civilización
contra contra que pues contra digamos
las gravar bari el salvajismo
y las culturas que se pueden considerar
inferiores entonces yo lo que pienso es
que pues
las reflexiones que decía que hacía a ti
son totalmente pertinentes para la
sociedad hoy en día porque lo otro que
es importante tener presente es que el
modelo de nación en el que seguimos
viviendo y que surge a partir del siglo
18 de los estados nacionales
surgen como una organización política
que busca que pretende la homogeneidad
cultural
la homogeneidad étnica a pesar de que no
se ha logrado y ese sigue siendo el
modelo que domina todavía el globo
entonces realmente estos temas son muy
pertinentes para el mundo de hoy no
porque hoy estamos hablando de
la fecha de 1492 y lo que eso quiso
decir hace cinco siglos
vivimos en un mundo donde esas
discusiones ya ya no importan siguen
siendo fundamentales para nuestras
sociedades y siguen siendo fundamentales
fernando en quito su opinión al respecto
sobre si este proceso debe seguir siendo
un reclamo después de tanto tiempo vamos
recogiendo las impresiones de las otras
dos invitadas y para que usted haga su
comentario
bueno
la historia no ha acabado no ha
concluido más hay una continuidad es por
eso que desde la visión de los pueblos
indígena originarios
exigimos toda esta reconstitución de los
procesos de las consecuencias de la
colonia porque tal vez desde europa hay
una visión una mirada distinta o una
percepción distinta pero desde los
pueblos indígenas originarios desde los
países de latinoamérica que todas las
nociones componentes vivimos acá las
consecuencias aún están vigentes es el
pensamiento colonial ese pensamiento
desde 1492 están vigentes en nuestra
piel 6 por ejemplo en bolivia hay
sectores racistas neocoloniales
neofascistas que aún promueven esa idea
donde la españa de 1492 de que los
pueblos indígenas no tienen derechos son
seres inferiores son bestias humanas son
hordas salvajes
por eso es que cuando hablan de
civilización definitivamente no estamos
de acuerdo porque no nos trajeron
civilización nos trajeron la premisa del
desencuentro entre nosotros y eso debe
ser resuelta y cuando hoy hablamos de
las realidades a través de la unión
europea la unión europea compuesta por
españa por portugal y otros países
deberían reconocer la deuda histórica
que tiene con los países de
latinoamérica fernando es instante
en el trato social bilateral
multilateral
por ejemplo la mirada sigue siendo
colonial cuando tratan de catalogar
cuando tratan de juzgar nuestros propios
procesos democráticos cuando ellos
quieren buscar a través de un
paternalismo aún todavía colonial que
tienen una mirada que debe ser de fuerza
fernando y habíamos dejado aquí sobre la
mesa la palabra sanar cómo empezar a
sanar desde su punto de vista cómo
empezar a acercar las partes llevamos
500 años debatiendo esto viendo todas
las perspectivas
analizándolo desde todos los puntos cómo
empezar a cortar distancias
es importante que nosotros ahora para
poder sanar porque creo que todos
nosotros este es un buen tiempo para
sanar porque esas heridas están vigentes
es resolver desde la honestidad
resolver desde la verdad
manifestando todo lo que realmente ha
sucedido y además tener una perspectiva
como vuelvo a reiterar los procesos
históricos están todavía en marcha
nosotros como países latinoamericanos
tenemos relaciones con la unión europea
miren desde bolivia por ejemplo cuando
queremos viajar a europa
nos piden visa por criterios económicos
eso no va a permitir sanar sanar
significa poner una una premisa de
encuentro verdadero de los países de los
continentes de la de las regiones eso
nos va a permitir sanar porque si bien
han pasado cinco centurias
529 años para nosotros es importante
ahora tener la mirada a los pueblos
indígenas originarios
ha dicho mi hermana ati quigua nosotros
vemos por esperanza el futuro con
esperanza tenemos que resolver temas
trascendentes como al cuidado a la madre
tierra porque no puede ser que se
produzca
destrozando la madre tierra eso no es
viable por lo tanto nosotros tenemos que
empezar a escuchar estas fotos
ancestrales para empezar a cuidar
nuestra casa traer nuestro hogar por lo
tanto aquí desde los pueblos indígena
originarios invitamos tanto a europa
como a los continentes para poder ver la
historia
desde la honestidad la sabiduría
ancestral que muchas veces ha sido
mirada por encima del hombro
alejandra le pregunto él más o menos el
mismo tema cómo empezar a acercar estas
opiniones desde el punto de vista suyo
desde el punto de vista académico
histórico cómo se puede empezar a
acercar partes y le hago la pregunta
antecediendo lo que le va a preguntar
el uso que se le ha dado a este tema a
nivel político
los gobiernos de diferentes países
argumentando que españa debería pedir
perdón que portugal debería pedir perdón
y que son comentarios que siguen
generando divisiones pero como empezamos
a juntar puntas del caos
claro
empezando por el hecho de que
los principales me atrevería a decir yo
con base en verdad en los principales
desafíos que enfrentan la gran cantidad
de pueblos indígenas que hay en américa
latina no vienen desde españa ni desde
portugal entonces no tenemos que perder
esa perspectiva
si bien el 12 de octubre es una
celebración que surge desde esa desde la
península ibérica en realidad los los
grandes desafíos existen en buena medida
también sobre todo al interior de
nuestros países no entre la clase
política entre las las
donde persisten como muy bien decía el
señor fernando mucha mucho racismo
donde se
irrespetan constantemente los derechos
de la internacionalmente reconocidos de
las poblaciones indígenas
y
y por lo tanto yo pienso que es
en la coyuntura actual
pensar que el enfrentamiento importante
es con españa con portugal no no tiene
realmente mayor asidero a pesar de que
en el 12 de octubre siempre salga el
tema en particular de ese vínculo con
españa entonces yo creo que en realidad
tenemos que vernos al interior como
estados nacionales
porque la el gran desafío es la
gigantesca deuda histórica que sobrevive
de los estados que existen hoy en día y
que se siguen replicando
históricamente del día con día con las
poblaciones indígenas no esa deuda
histórica
definitivamente si no hay un
reconocimiento de esa deuda histórica
no pueden pensar en el saneamiento el
saneamiento no es encontrar un punto
medio entre dos puntos extremos es
buscar cuál es la posición más justa y
más respetuosa de la diversidad y de los
derechos de la gente entonces no puede
ser simplemente buscar un punto medio
entre los extremos sino que tiene que
haber ese criterio de reconocimiento de
la deuda histórica
reconocimiento a ti en parte de esa
nación que es el tema que estábamos
analizando y que dejamos aquí sobre la
mesa reconocer esto como un genocidio
puede ser un parte de un punto de
partida para esa sanación para
restablecer cordialidad bueno yo quiero
hablar de cuatro
sanaciones que me parecen fundamentales
sanar el ser
sanar el poder sanar el territorio y
sanar el saber cuando digo sanar el ser
quiero decir que cada ser humano debe
ser consciente desde que el ente se está
mirando el mundo porque nosotros
naturalizamos y quiero invitar a la
humanidad a entender que nuestra mayor
riqueza es la diversidad cultural que
eso nos debe alegrar a todos
como un patrimonio invaluable en ese
sentido
yo creo que es invitarlos a todos a una
lucha contra la homogenización porque
ahí está detrás una violencia sutil pero
en la más profunda
sanar el poder yo creo que hay que tener
claro cuáles son las relaciones de poder
y yo quiero decir que hay un poder
abusivo económico político que sigue
imponiendo sus discursos sus modelos
saqueando nuestros territorios y sobre
el cuerpo y el territorio de las mujeres
indígenas recae toda esa violencia voy a
poner un ejemplo solamente
amazonía
revolución industrial siglo 19
surgimiento de la industria automotriz
la extracción del caucho significó la
esclavitud y todo tipo de vejámenes el
genocidio de más de 40 mil indígenas y
yo creo que es importante un paso que se
ha dado en colombia con los acuerdos de
paz y es reconocer las violencias
particulares que han afectado a los
pueblos indígenas y reconocerlas
precisamente para
repararlas y para no seguirlas
reproduciendo ahora sanar el saber yo
pienso que los sistemas de conocimiento
de los pueblos indígenas necesitan ser
parte del sistema educativo necesitan
ser reconocidos es decir parte de la
sanación es un diálogo horizontal de
saberes si desde un idioma dominante o
desde una mirada y una perspectiva
académica racista lo que mira al otro
como analfabeto como ignorante en esas
condiciones no vamos a sanar
es necesario partir de ese diálogo de
saberes y por otro pues sanar el
territorio la reconciliación con la
tierra creo que la pandemia nos dejó una
lección y es que somos seres
interdependientes lo que le suceda a la
amazonía nos sucede a todos lo que le
suceda a la sierra nevada de santa marta
estamos interconectados entonces yo creo
que estas divisiones
político-administrativas las hemos
creado los seres humanos no es verdad
estamos unidos somos uno entonces yo
creo que esta perspectiva
más holística de los pueblos nos hermana
nos nos une a una origen común me quedan
5 minutos de programa rápidamente viendo
esta parte del discurso político que ahí
vemos al presidente de méxico haciendo
cada septiembre que es la fecha de
independencia de méxico y cada octubre
cuando llega esta fecha cuando llega el
12 de octubre haciendo este reclamo
españa incluso los pueblos originarios
de méxico no apoyan estos reclamos de
que españa tiene que darle una disculpa
a méxico por lo ocurrido allí su
perspectiva sobre este tema sobre este
discurso político que sigue generando
yo pienso que más que un discurso por
favor necesitamos transformar las
relaciones económicas y las relaciones
políticas es decir
necesitamos realmente que la cooperación
internacional sea para que juntos
salgamos pues de esta crisis
civilizatoria y construyamos juntos el
buen vivir de la humanidad en ese
sentido pues yo pienso que más que un
reclamo y más que un discurso
necesitamos transformar nuestras
relaciones políticas y económicas
transformación sería el resumen de esta
intervención alejandra doctora alejandra
lien sanjosé su opinión sobre estos
discursos que todavía existen vienen del
presidente de mexico de nicolás maduro
en venezuela que siguen insistiendo en
este tipo de reclamos históricos y
generando división como lo ve usted
pues
pienso que en principio se basan en
en un efecto que realmente es decir que
realmente hay en el fondo detrás del
discurso político puede haber un reclamo
justificado el problema es el uso
político que se da de ese reclamo en uso
político cuyo objetivo no necesariamente
es y la mayoría de las veces no es
realmente fortalecer la posición de las
poblaciones indígenas en nombre de las
cuales supuestamente se hace tal reclamo
sino que tiene otros objetivos de
política interna e internacional en los
que realmente se instrumentaliza el tema
para lograr otros objetivos entonces lo
que yo pienso es que
distraen a propósito se usan para
distraer la atención de lo que son pues
los reclamos sustantivos y realmente
que entran que que ponen digamos lo
hacían a cada uno de nuestros estados a
tener que ver realmente a profundidad su
origen y eso es lo que se está invitando
a ser vamos llegando ya al cierre del
programa fernando lo dijo para que
responda rápidamente muy puntual por
favor sobre este uso político que se le
da estos reclamos y también su
conclusión vamos a llegar a un acuerdo
histórico nos vamos a entender entre
todos en américa latina' con la visión
que podemos tener de esta fecha y sobre
este momento histórico para nuestro
continente y para nuestros pueblos
originarios que fue un impacto pues que
vemos las repercusiones hasta el día de
hoy
la deuda histórica debe ser de suelo por
lo menos así es el sentimiento no
solamente de una nación indígena
originaria no solamente de un país
latinoamericano sino es un sentimiento
de todo el continente o que es una
realidad por lo tanto hoy en los nuevos
procesos históricos deben tener y
debemos partir de una premisa los
pueblos indígena originarios han
invitado al continente al mundo
nuevamente reconstituir la cultura de la
vida el vivir bien buen vivir el su baja
mañana sumar caos que no solamente va a
resolver esta etapa física de nuestra
historia sino la perspectiva de la
crisis de la humanidad sea así que en
ese sentido debemos ahora ver esta nueva
perspectiva de la historia para resolver
esta crisis que todos estamos viendo
desde los pueblos indígena originarios
es respeto a la pachamama respecto a la
biblia no se recupera
bueno pues a fernando a la doctora
alejandra de yate aquí en el estudio
france24 les agradezco por haber
compartido con nosotros sus puntos de
vista sobre este tema que sigue
generando controversia no solamente en
nuestro continente sino también en
españa y también en brasil y en portugal
a ustedes también les agradezco la
sintonía pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales que les mencionaba al inicio
del programa pueden responder también la
encuesta que está en línea recuerda que
en france 24 punto como pueden ver este
y otros episodios de el debate en nombre
de la producción del programa les
agradezco su sintonía siga con nosotros
[Música]